it's time for drew's news your good news
flashlight in the middle of the night i
personally like a headlamp um hands-free
and with me at the desk the best
co-pilot in the business rossi ross
matthew yes hi everybody hi
hi
i
love you in an olive this is the first
time i've worn this jacket you like i
love i got it at the mall myself i did
it
and the collar on your shirt very unique
yeah i took a risk and you i heard you
back say you said you were doing a diane
chambers look is that what you said no
but they were playing cheers backstage
i'm binging cheers on hulu right now on
the train and it's like
some of her looks totally remind me of
you you could pull any sort of blouse
sleeve i love the diane chambers
reference i will take it you are welcome
for that thank you shelley and we are
sort of the sam and diana daytime will
we won't me you know what i mean
usually i'm
hawking the idea to you and you're like
what what are you talking about my girl
wrong tree you're barking let's move on
i know it's my life pattern to bark up
the wrong tree i know you're not
interested in me rossi i'm interested
you in every way but one and that's why
this works exactly cheers to you and i
am the flower girl at your wedding yes
you are
all right well before we hit the
headlines we have a psa for anyone who's
about to take their passport photo yeah
how do i know this well i just tried to
upload my new passport photo and i got a
message
that said my photo was rejected
and the reason why was a smile was
detected look at her
i look too happy you do they rejected my
photo
and here is my fully approved passport
photo
can you believe this
does anyone know that you are not
allowed to smile in a passport photo
raise of hands who knows this
oh everybody
well
in your defense i only know this because
they told me stop smiling when i got the
picture taken why is it hello we're
literally going into other countries we
don't want to do it smiling like
i'm friendly hello but like
what's the difference it's still me
um well okay so everybody now knows
no smile
welcome to the country
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right that's hilarious too this
story is uh very meaningful um everyone
is tuning in to amy poehler's
directorial intimate portrait of lucille
ball and desi arnaz called lucy and desi
the new york times reports that the new
amazon documentary tells the story of
the couple in their own words amy went
through hours of audio tapes to
reconstruct their incredible story now
if you've seen the movie that's out
obviously right now this is a completely
different take take a look
i love lucy built every episode around
that idea of fracture and coming back
together and i think we crave that as
humans no matter what you've done i
forgive you
will you still love me you don't
necessarily have to be a funny person to
get a laugh
[Music]
i'm not a funny person
[Music]
the show was one of the most wonderful
things happened in my life
we brought the raptors down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at the core
it's all about unconditional love
you know i feel good
oh my god
it's hardcore but i've been watching it
and it is
so detailed and it goes you think you
know the story and amy shows us
it's so much deeper in their own words
it's so intimate it's so well done amy
said that she wanted to expand our
definition of what a successful
partnership looks like
oh god and lucy and desi got divorced
but they co-parented and remained loving
and respectful partners until the end
this really strikes a chord yeah
it really does
i just found this whole project
fascinating i can't recommend enough on
amazon right now good job amy
[Music]
you